>> BLAIN: Hello, everybody. I'm Matthew Blain
and I'm a member of the Google App Engine
team, I'm one of the engineers on it and I'm
here to talk to you today about the Bulkloader.
The title of this talk is Data Migration with
App Engine. So, you can follow along with
the presentation, we'll be taking notes on
Google Wave and you can also find sample code
which I'd be referencing throughout the presentation
on bulkloadersample.appspot.com where you
can look at the wave at bit.ly/appengine4.
So, I'm going to give you a bit of background
about the Bulkloader and what you need to
know to understand the Bulkloader. Tell you
a bit about how the Bulkloader works. To show
you how to create your own configurations
for the Bulkloader, talk a bit about some
of the advance features you'd use to create
sort of more complicated configurations and
tell you a bit about troubleshooting and the
feature directions for the Bulkloader. All
right, so what is the Bulkloader? How many
of you actually use the Bulkloader in App
Engine? All right, a good number of you, that's
good. So, the Bulkloader is a tool for datastore
import and export in App Engine. So, you can
use it to import data set in to App Engine
from like CSV file and external database or
something. You can export out of App Engine
similarly to a CSV file or external database.
You can also use it to migrate data between
application and since it--so, for example,
people have demonstrated use like a QA server
and a production server, if you'd setup to
QA, you know, move it for your production
server. You can also move between dev app
server and production which is also particular
use from QA. Even though the title of this
talk is Data Migration in App Engine, it's
not really about schema migration. I suppose
you could use the Bulkloader for by downloading
all of your data. If one schema then uploading
it all to a slightly different schema to a
different kind, it's not meant for that, it
could work for it. So, again I'm going to
show you how to configure and use the Bulkloader.
So, just a bit of background of, I'm guessing
everyone haven't used the Bulkloader has used
the App Engine datastore but how many of you
are familiar with App Engine datastore? Well,
I guess, that's good. But just a bit of review,
basically you have schemeless tables of entities.
Every sort of table in relational terms is
one kind of entity called an App Engine. Every
entity is a single key which is the identity
of the entities. You can fetch an entity by
keys which is also indexes which you can use
to sort of--well, if you want to do other
queries, more interesting than just get me
the key X. And keys are not hierarchical but
they're actually they're--they're kind of
for entity groups, this will become important
later, you can have apparent keys on your
keys and properties are types. So there's
no schema on a kind but typically you have
a bunch of different property--a bunch of
different properties on it and they have particular
types but not all strings. In Python, you
wrap this model class, in Java you can wrap
this with JDO or JPA or whatever annotations
and there's other wrappers for other languages
which people have running on the JVM and App
Engine. So, the fundamentals of what the Bulkloader
does is it takes your data from your external
source, converts them all to the datastore
entities, the type to use an App Engine and
it just shifts it over to the datastore and
HTTP. One thing is sort of important to note
is that the Bulkloader is actually running
on your client work station. This is how we
get around things like 30-second limits and
small amounts of upload is that we do the
primary work on your local works station then
to shift the data of to App Engine. And just
a bit of background, you all have seen an
App Engine after run it, you can run App Server
or on production. One of the frequently ask
questions people have is, does it only work
on Python or do you have a Java version available?
And the answer is that the server runs either
on Python or on Java. The client, however,
we only have one client right now, it's implemented
in Python. [INDISTINCT] Python 134SDK particularly
for the new configuration format I'm talking
about today. You'll need the newest version
of SDK and you need Python to run it, don't
need anything else. You don't need any particular
IDs or anything like that. All right. So,
how does the Bulkloader work? And just a quick
demo. Actually, before we even get to that,
I sort of remind people about zero configuration,
its features been out for a little bit but
as I mentioned particular if you're migrating
data from one instance to another or you just
take a daily back up or something, for example,
if you're--it's a good thing to do before
you do schema migration, you backup all of
your data incase something goes horribly wrong.
You can just dump your data from App Engine
to your local work station. One thing which
is it somewhat new is that this is a fully
integrated App CFG right now, you can also
use the bulkloader but basically you just
run this command App CFG download data pointer
application, point for local file name, runs
and the inverse upload data. All right. So,
I'm just going to do quick demo using the
new configuration format which came out in
134. All right, so, my wonderful demo system--all
right. For a second--so, I'm going to be demoing
with the guestbook application. This is the
same application that you see with either
of getting starter guide for Java or for Python.
So, I have just some very simple sample data,
the guestbook has just comments, data comments
are written, the author that--who wrote the
comments. So, I'm going to upload the data,
all right. Upload the data command, it's got
lots of command and arguments but, basically,
it says here is the file, here is the configuration,
here is the destination. And if we actually
look at our guestbook now, it has the same
exact--same comments we just uploaded, I could
say something else. Hello, IO, good afternoon.
And we can also download them, pretty much
the same way. All right, so, here's the downloaded
data. You should see, hello, IO, good afternoon,
right their. So how do that work? So, a simple
data we've got the model, this is the model
many of you familiar with. We've gone through
the sample and this is the same thing in Java.
Right there is actually equivalent applications.
I happen to be running the Python one here
today. So how did it work? So, this is described,
this is the new configuration format, this
is probably the first time that many of you
have seen the configuration format. It's designed
to be declarative so that if your Java developer
or some other language developer not necessarily
Python developer, you don't actually need
to understand Python. It's still somewhat
based on Python but the fundamentals are designed
to be just basically declarative. So it described
that we have a kind greeting that it came
from a CSV file and it has three properties.
Basically, the first property is a string,
the second property is a user property, third
property is a date. Dates are a little bit
more complicated because we have to define
the formats the date is in because CSV files
are strings and dates are internally are all
set for an app or something like that. So
the way it works is that the Bulkloader is
a three phase process. There's sort of there's
three transitions. This is going to--this
is the first two of the transitions. So on
import, we have our data CSV file, you see
it's cool stuff, comma date, comma some author.
What we have is called the connector for the
first phase. So the connector takes the data
from the external format and in this case,
CSV and converts it until they call neutral
dictionary. The dictionary is just dictionary
of key value pairs representing each row basically
in your input data. The reason for this intermediate
format is that we can have different connectors
not necessarily CSV but any format can happen
into internal dictionary to pass onto the
next stage which is basically what the property
map describe us to do or retransform this
dictionary in to a datastore entity. So as
you can see that the property--the amo file
who describe that content had no transform,
the date had this transformed with this strings
specifying the date format and the user just
specified the user property. So it passed
into these three arguments and then we basically
got entity which deserve Python representation
of the type data, again, the string, a date
and a user property. The next phase as I mentioned
earlier, we found this on a client work station
and now we're going to upload it to the server.
So, this uses a remote_API as many group are
familiar with this but basically every single--every
single API called an App Engine effect is
an RPC. So, what remote_API does is we're
actually running basically the full App Engines
stacks similar to a dev App server on your
local client workstation and the data start
calls remoted using remote_API to the server.
The other interesting thing to know about
the upload part and this whole process is
that it's actually done in parallel. We run
mutltiple threads, the defaults four threads
like a four clouds here. An upload because
it has all the data locally and is pushing
to the datastore with identified keys, well
let that in a minute. It does the full conversion
process and parallel on download because you
want to order of your output file to be the
order of your original data. They actually
downloads all the data locally and then runs
over this transform step after it's done downloading
all the data. The other piece you need to
enable remote_API is sort of a quick reminder.
You can see this in documentation. I'm trying
to hear it partly because the most common
error that people make when they turn on remote_API
is that they have some sort of catch all handler
in our application and they promote remote_API
after it. So, the simplest advice just put
it first thing in your app.amo or first thing
in your web.xml, this is the equivalent--the
exact the same equivalent in Java for handling
the exact same case. All right, so how do
you create these configurations on your own?
The most important thing you'll get out of
this talk today. So, it's a big wall of text
I just showed you this sort of the key pieces
of the configuration for the guestbook but
if you provided yourself, we've actually provided
a wizard to create it. So, anyone, have ideas
on how it gets--how it gets the data that
actually create those test?
>> Stats.
>> BLAIN: Stats, all right, you got it. So,
the data source are just---are features that's
have been at App Engine for a while. If you
seen them in the--in your admin console, it
says, "Here's how much data you have of this
kind. How many, how much data you have of
this property, of this type of property?"
The datastore statistics are actually themselves
stored in your datastore. So, if you're interested
in seeing sort of slightly more complexed
Bulkloader configuration, you can actually
look at how the Bulkloader creates the Bulkloder
configuration. If you don't care, you can
just use it. Don't worry about it. But basically
trade Bulkloader config itself actually uses
the Bulkloader to download your data. So,
again, just a quick demo, this is the command
line app CFG create Bulkloader config. One
of the disadvantages of using datastore stats
is that they're only available on production
and they take up to a day to generate. So,
if you modified your schema very recently,
you basically have to wait a day to use a
Bulkloader; you just have to fall back to
editing, follow yourself I guess. So, here
we go and here's the auto generated file.
This is in fact just what was created right
now. You can see I have--this is a bunch of
boilerplate at the top, some instructions
and then there is several different properties
which I have them in my demo app permits several
different entity kinds I have in my demo app
which you can modify. All right. So, what
do you need to do after you've created the
auto generated file? It's not completely automatic,
right, you're not totally done but actually
in many cases you are already done. If you
have a simple schema like the guestbook one,
quiet possibly all you need to do is set the
connector. So, in this case I'm supposed to
saying connector CVS said to do and the default
options for some of the connectors are pretty
simple. It's pretty common that default encoding
for them is UTF-8 all the ones that we're
shipping right now. CSV files are pretty frequently
in Windows-1252, so you might want to add
including Windows-1252. And you also want
to review the property map. It's most like
the thing you're going to need to do next.
So, keys are actually really interesting and
spend a bunch of time talking about that in
a few minutes. You also may need to check
for duplicates, pretty rare, but if you have--you
know, datastore statistics you've had a schema
change. You've changed specifically from the
phone number type to a string type or vice
versa. You may have some entities which are--which
the datastore statistics have noticed which
are the old types; you just seemed to go and
delete that. And there's a bunch of to-do's
you have to deal with. So, let me talk about
the keys for a minute. So if you're used to
the relational model, you have primary keys
and foreign keys not quiet the same thing
in App Engine. This is the schema for the,
let's say SQL schema somewhat similar to their
app, some Bulkloader sample, which I just
downloaded to create the wizard for it. And
so, instead of a primary key App Engine again,
every entity has a key called as a primary
key, there's also references may have seen
that the talk about the corporate applications
we got in Google and talked about reference
keys and some of them. And you can basically
use a key to identify another particular entity
of another kind. There's also entity groups
which I mentioned earlier. These are typically
use for transactional reasons but you may
in fact use them for actually structuring
your data, in particular, in Java, their own
relationships, and also just to reminder for
those of you who familiar with it or something
new for those who don't. When you have keys
in your entities, there's basically two types;
one is the auto generated key. If you don't
really care about the key, what it means,
App Engine will auto generate one for you
which is a number associated with it. The
numbers increment overtime approximately no
particular guarantees about them being unique.
You can also have a developer named key; this
particular useful if you care about your key
structure. There's something really easy to
calcu1ate to identify a key. Say you have
a blog with post on it or Wikipedia articles
or you have a user object, it represents a
particular user. It's often really useful
to use, for example, if you use the Google
account API, we'd give you a unique user ID
for every user. You can just use that as the
key and so the useful because if you have
any instances where you have this thing which
you identify, you can then look up whatever
you want just by key. And these are also particularly
useful for creating relations. So, again,
if you have bunch of tables in here, and say,
you've exported from a database in different
CSV modules, you can then calculate the keys
so you can create your create your references
automatically. So, common--most common case,
the key with no parent, where you set the
entity key is pseudo property__key__. This
shouldn't conflict of any of your properties
because we claim everything underscore is
reserved. So, if you just specify a string
on import that will just create a named key.
You do need to actually use a transform. We've
provided a bunch of helper functions. I haven't
mentioned it yet, but there's a whole library
called "transform" which is imported by default
in the auto-generated Bulkloader.amo. It's
got a bunch of helpers. One of them is key_id_or_name_as_string,
this one is basically safe. If you happen
to have a mix of IDs and names, it will just
printout the ID or the name as a string. There
are some other helpers if you want to distinguish
between them in your output. And for reference
properties, we also created another method
which is called "create foreign keys." So
if the schema identifies anything that's having
a key in the datastore statistics, the auto-generated
amo will actually just fill in the transform
fill with to do. We have to specify the kind
and that's all they need if it's just a single
level key. All right, so this is an example
from the schema. We've got a customer and
a visit. Every visit has one customer. And
we have an external visit ID. The export--I
know it's always names, so I can actually
use a simpler key name. I should have used
the example which I had before. And then it
has a customer property, which in this case
is an extra hand of customer. This is just
supposed to be the--this is the name part
of the customer key. So again, transform.create_foreign_key_('customer')
will just generate that. On the parent keys,
I mentioned are used for creating entity groups
or on relationships. So, you'd probably actually
shouldn't do this. I'll explain that you should
probably be using--those properties for this
but--let's say you want to actually have the
visit and the visit activity has represent
exactly the schema, where we have Visit and
the visit activities to handle the one too
many relationship. You can do this by creating
entity group for each visit, and we've provided
a bunch of helper functions. Again, this transform
method, which call--I called it "create deep
key." So, every key is identified. Every level
of the key is identified by the kind and then
the identity. So in this case, the--this helper
function knows how to pullout the visit column,
associated with the visit kind, pulls out
the activity column associates it with the
visit activity kind which is in fact not listed
here, but it's the kind that we're importing.
And on export, it's actually also the first
time I've shown this to you guys, which is
that since this is a multicolumn thing, we
have one key, which is representing the CSV
as two different columns. On import there's
one function which knows how to actually look
at the whole rows of--holistically and actually
pulls out the different columns that needs
to create the key. On export we actually can
specify two different exports. So we have
the export to the external column visit. Export
to the external column activity. And they
have two different transforms which run the
function, just pulls the key apart. So as
I've mentioned, you'd probably don't actually
want to use an owned relationship for this
very simple visit activity. You actually want
to use the much more efficient list property
which is present in App Engine to generate--just
put them all in the same entity. So, when
you fetch the entity, you get all the data.
So, if you know your schema you'll know this
when your editing the file, but you may, you
may have forgotten about it. You may just
be reviewing the auto-generated amo file.
The statistics unfortunately don't actually
know about list properties. What they do know
is, sort of, the count of properties you've
of each kind. So in this case, we have about
twice as many activities as we have customers,
so it's a good chance that list property you
should obviously review your own model, your
own job and notations to verify this. But
it's a sort of a glaring note that, by the
way, this one is special, and you should probably
do something about with it. So what do you
actually do with it? Again, this is sort of
the simplest way to deal with it. If you have
something like CSV file, and you've already
auto-generated it in some system. If you have
one of the columns is itself some sort of
delimited colon. In this is I used a semicolon,
it's different from a comma. Try to the helpers
called "split string," "join list" because
it's a type properties. These helpers will
return a list of strings or take a list of
strings and split it out. These are actually
types, so if you do something else, listed
integers, you actually want to do something
slightly different. All right, so that's sort
of just a basic overview of how you auto-generate
amo, some of the thing you want to do when
reviewing it. It'll auto-generate some of
the most basic types, these are just some
of the transforms. You'll want to look into
the transform class to actually see a list.
And the other transforms, I will be providing
more later. So let's talk about some sort
of more advanced configuration. Multiple tables,
again, let's imagine we have this visit and
visit activity table, and it's actually represented
as two different tables and say in a relational
database. And you don't necessarily want to
actually to write the preprocessing to smash
them together. How do you handle that? Right
now, actually, the example that I'm giving
actually sort of--this [INDISTINCT] this,
it actually does actually use some sort of
preprocessing. If you're a database or you
have a tool, which exists--can output in a
hierarchy format. So, instead of just taking
like a CSV file and smashing the hierarchy
into using semicolons, and hoping you get
the escaping right. If you have something
like an XML file, we actually provide also
an XML connect. So, since this is natively
hierarchal we can do something much more interesting
with it. So this is just a quick intro to
the XML connector. It's called "simplexml"
because it only handles really, really simple
XML right now. Someday, we can imagine someone
writing a more complicated one. But basically,
you provide the XPath, which represents each
of the primary entity. In this case visit
is the XPath. There's multiple visit nodes
you can imagine. And it handles both element
centric and attribute centric, but for this
case we're going to use the element centric
schema. Then we have the list properties,
so all the other properties alighted here
they worked just like before and to say, you
know, whatever the primary key and et cetera.
But what we can do is we say this cctivity
is propered, it's list property. Again, I'm
just going to provide a helper here, which
says list list_from_xml_node. And they all
look at the source of the helper. It's kind
of interesting. You may look at the source
of helpers, kind of interesting. I'll go into
this later how it actually works. But basically
again, it looks holistically at the thing
similar to the way they create deep key work.
And it actually looks at the XML node, runs
a different XPath on it for the activities,
pulls out all the activities and generates
a list out that. And on export, it does sort
of the inverse. It takes all the activities
and actually converts it into a list. So,
the neutral dictionary--for a CVS file, all
in the neutral dictionary is just going to
be strings. But for other file types, it's
actually not necessary that the dictionary
only have strings in it. In this case, simplexml
supports on output if you have, basically,
a dictionary as one of the items. In the dictionary
it'll actually create the child nodes for
you. So that's what the x--the transform helper
on export does, it actually puts a dictionary
in dictionary, recursively because it's recursive
format. So, how does this work? How would
you write your own code? And going to that.
So, this is the first time I've actually shown
a Python code here since the Bulkloader is
written in Python you won't need to list have
some basic understanding of Python. So, this
is sort of a composite slide of three different
ways of doing the same thing. So you can actually
have an inline lambda in your transform. So
similar to how you just--if you just specify
let's say "int." That's actually the Python
in conversion function. You can specify a
lambda function. So in this case, I've just
specified a lambda which takes the value,
just passed in, converts it into an integer,
multiplies it by two. You can also do something
very similar to the transforms we've help
provided in the transform.pie or the sample
transform helper.pie. Where if you want to
do something multiple times, you know, and
it's like copy and paste this lambda 50 times
in your file. You can just define a function
double--again, it takes one argument. It takes
the value, it converts to and then it returns
it. And then your import transform, you just
reference it. You've import your module called
"double." And the third thing you can do,
and this is what many of the transform helpers
do or sort of going far more complicated here
is if you want to have a function which takes
an argument. So in this case, this is a sample
multiply function it takes a multiple and
actually returns a function using sub-closures
in Python. So, you import transform--if you
say my module multiply three, we're now tripling
instead of doubling the number. And my module
multiply three is itself a function. So when
we pass in the string, you know, "1 1", it
all converted into an integer and triple it
and you get back 33. But that doesn't explain
how the listing--or the deep key functions
work. How do we actually get this information,
because they only pass in a single value,
a single column? And the answer, how those
work is if you specify a keyword argument
bulkload state typically it's a second argument,
but it actually has explicitly that name.
We pass in this bulkload state object which
what you see the bigger picture of what's
actually happening. So get things like the
filename, loader options, and explore options
pass in the command line but more interestingly
you get the current dictionary and the current
instance which is being transported. So when
you're doing this--the way it worked with
sort of created a deep key or the ones that
took the XML and convert into a list, is that
the function knew we provided an XPath into
the XML node. We look at the bulkload state
for the current dictionary and the current
dictionary in the XML converter contains the
node itself as one of it properties. So we
looked at that and said, "Okay, we're going
to run this XPath on it. Do a bunch of information
and return this list property." Similarly,
for the one which create a deep key, it actually
said, "OK, here are the columns I care about
for my keys so it was visit and activity."
Actually, look to the dictionary and said,
"Okay, I'm going to look for the visit property
in the dictionary, the activity property in
the dictionary. Combined them together and
create a deep key." In fact, here's a simplified
version of create deep key. So again, this
is one of these things that are just in the
closure so that it can be reused in multiple
different amo files. And, we have a transfer
function and we'd basically go through the
list of kinds and column that were provided
in the amo file and pullout the information
from the dictionary. So the kind column is
something that would specify in the amo file
and the result is basically we take this,
iterate through it, and calls the key from
path function which is how you build one of
these hierarchal keys in the Python data story
behind. The other useful thing, so, sort of,
mention you could sort of introspect in the
state on your transforms. You can also do
a post processing as post import function,
post export function. These will take--it
will take, it will pass an entire dictionary
that the neutral dictionary and the entire
entity, in both directions, we pass both of
them. And you can do whatever you want with
it. So you could for example have no, nothing
in your property map and have a post import
or post export functions which did all the
work yourself. I'm not quite sure why you'd
do that. More useful is that, you can do filtering.
So on import, you can say, "Okay." For some
reason this is invalid or its nothing that
I care about, it's going to return none, similarly
on export. In fact, that's how the Bulkloader
takes it is, sorts it, it provides a useful
Bulkloader.amu because it's actually a bunch
of noise in the data source, we just don't
care about. So it just says return none on
all those. The other thing you can do on import,
you can't don't this on export which you can
actually provide a second kind. That becomes
interesting if you sort of doing data de-normalization
or normalization of some form on your imported
function. It's not particularly easy to do
right now, so I'm just going to skip over
that. I'll [INDISTINCT]. The other interesting
thing is writing your own connector. So the
CSV is not the whole world, right. I mean,
sure you can export most databases into CSV
rights and processing. Even XML, it's a very
basic XML kind of, you can do hierarchy. But,
let's say you want to talk with some other
file format like a database format or even
a connection to a live database or even other
websites. I think somebody asked some question
about gdata on the wave before the talk. You
can write your own connector. There's a simple
connector interface. Although, actually as
we've been sort of extending beyond the simple
model of files. It has some limitations that
might change, but it'll certainly stay there,
there's a backwards compatible version. So,
this is actually a complete connector on the
screen right here. The--when you notice, for
example, I set the encoding option in CSV
connector much earlier in the demo. The connector
gets this when it gets--there's a method you
define to create your connector, in this case,
it's just a contracture of the object, you
can just get it from the dictionary. And on
import, there's just one method, which returns
[INDISTINCT], in this case generate import
records, so I'm just reading JSON. So, this
format is particularly useful if you have
something that you can say, export to a hierarchal
format. Each line in the file represents a
row, and each line actually represents a JSON
document. So it's not actually one JSON files,
multiple JSON documents in a single file.
Open the file, for every line in the file
just run simple JSON [INDISTINCT] it and yield
it, it's generates--it a very simple way we
by implementing this. On export, very similar.
There's three methods instead of one. You've
got initialized methods which open the file.
For every dictionary it gets passed in, we
do something interesting with it. In this
case, we just [INDISTINCT] it using simple
JSON and write it, on its own mind and we're
done, we close the file to clean-up after
ourselves. All right, so now you've sort of
learned sort of how the Bulkloader works,
how to write your own connectors, how to write
your own configuration file. It's going to
go to a couple little of tips about how to
use the Bulkloader. One of the particular
things which happens a lot when using the
Bulkloader because your running them your
client and because your application is sitting
on a server is, things happen. It may get
aborted. You may temporarily run-out of quota.
You know, someone may trip over the wire and
disconnect you, whatever. You may have an
error. You can resume both uploads and downloads.
You don't have to just start from scratch.
So, on uploads you need to pass db filename
that's where the Bulkloader stores its state
about, "Okay, how far long am I into this
file? What's going on?" On downloads you need
to pass both the state and the result db filename.
As I mentioned earlier it downloads everything.
And then it runs it through the transform.
This is also particularly useful on export.
You can use this for a couple of things. You
can--if you sort of just messed up you export
transform, you don't need to re-download all
your data. You can just rerun it, point to
the same result db file and run over it. You
can also do tricks where you use different
formats. So if you downloaded the data and
want to run some sort of two different reports
or something on the same data, you can specify
to Bulkloader.amo files on the same result
database. So talk about tuning, so, I mentioned
much earlier that it runs in parallel, and
the downloads run in parallel, and the upload
is running in parallel too. They're all running
in parallel. There's a couple of different
arguments, these are just three of the common
ones, you need to deal with. Because of the
limitations and code on App Engine, unfortunately,
frequently you need to tune this down to much
smaller sizes than a default. However, you
can also generally tune and turn up the number
of threads. So, the Bulkloader is actually
making estimations on the client of what your
server can handle, it's based on some of the
rules and some of the codes that we have.
And actually in the last maybe year or so,
since we originally wrote this code, some
of the rules we've had have actually changed
and relax, so it's destinations off and off.
So unfortunately, it usually just works but
occasionally de-tune it, so fairly common
tuning operations turned down the number of
request the number of data that sent at any
one time, and turn off the number of threads
so you can do more things in parallel. You
can also as I noted run it against the dev
app server. The Python want a single threaded,
so if you use the default number threads for
and have lots of data, it will actually dive
our way through which probably [INDISTINCT]
if you don't do this but, you can specify
number threads equals one. All right, so those
are some service tips tuning and running it,
start about troubleshooting for a bit. So,
as I mentioned earlier, when I showed you
the web XML and the app.amo, the remote API
URL is frequently configured wrong. It should
say the request do not contain in the necessary
header, it's kind of goofy error message,
it's just saying that you're browser is not
the remote API client, and you should be using
remote API client. But it's also not telling--it
also, it ensures that when you're logging
in, you can log in as an admin and that's
configured correctly, it doesn't say show
the homepage of your application which you
might do of the of the cache or handler. And
you also need to specify the user remote API
URL in the Bulkloader configuration if using
--URL. If you're using a Python application,
you can actually just specify an app directory
just like you do for the upload and download
and all those other operations, it'll actually
automatically infer things for you. For a
job developer, at the moment you have to use
--URL. And so, debugging the config file.
So, since the config file is sort of a fairly
clean format, the-–it'll spit out error
messages telling your line numbers and error
messages. Hopefully, they're helpful. Occasionally,
if the actual Python file your importing contains
an error, it will tell you there's an error
not line of the app.amo and it's just telling
you that in fact there's an error in the Python
file which is referenced on that line. On
import, you can run a dry run. So the dry
run takes all of your data, runs it through
all of the import transforms, but doesn't
actually write it through datastore. So this
is useful particular validation. I didn't
mention this, you can actually use a Python
model to ensure your validation. And basically,
I'm sure that it can pass you your entire
input file without actually writing any data.
And of course you can display it through that
app server both for upload and download because
small sets of data, just always a good practice.
All right, so, talking a bit about the future
directions, so, dressing the pain. So, the
whole point of the Bulkloader, of course,
is to make your life easier when you're moving
data in and out of App Engine. So, just showed
you some of the transforms today, you may
have notice someone said transform reference
have transformed, that's because I wrote them
in the [INDISTINCT] instead of in the actual
SDK. We'll be adding more useful ones in the
SDK. This is also an opportunity sort of for
you, the general audience, or anyone to contribute
since the SDKs is in fact an open source project
give useful ones, which only opens to eventually
more connector. So right now, we only have
CSV and XML connectors and this demo simple
JSON one. Obviously, wants someone that's
actually connects to a real database is perhaps
using the standard Python database interface
so that you can connect to multi-database,
start writing your own connector, exporting
data. And the real big one, the server side
processing. So I've talked about this tuning
and these errors you can get. On a road map,
are things like map reduce and long running
processes, and we're investigating which of
those sort of most useful way of actually
handling data entirely on the server. So this
isn't useful, necessarily if you're running
a local SQL database connection though, actually,
I have some ideas on how to make that work
too. It's particularly useful if you have
entire CSV file, and you can export your entire
database. Usually, we upload it using the
[INDISTINCT] API and app engine. Here's the
giant blob, a single HTTP connection, it's
very reliable. And then we can run it on the
applications server, iterate through all of
your data on the server side, and it's basically
gets rid of the most common pain point people
have which is the Bulkloader today which is
at something happens at some point during
the transfer process and, you know, you have
to debug that and deal with that. All right,
so just a summary, Q&A. So, just a reminder,
the Bulkloader runs on your workstation, transforms
data, loads it at the server. If you don't
want to do any configuration, you're just
moving data backing it up, moving up from
server to from client from one instance to
another. We got a zero configuration, even
automatic configuration tool. So, you don't
actually have to write one of these Bulkloader
configurations from scratch, but, we've got
lots of helpers and transform for help to
make your life easier, and you can also write
your own helpers, write your own connectors,
and just--keys are to key to creating relationships
if you have more than one table and you have
an example probably more complicated than
the initial Bulkloader, initial guess book
example. All right, so, I guess, I gave you
lots of time for Q&A. So, any questions--microphone.
I'm going to see if I can open the wave here.
Any hope for Java version? So, let me ask
you why, I guess, why...
>> [INDISTINCT] speaks Python.
>> BLAIN: Is that what?
>> I don't speak Python.
>> BLAIN: You don't speak Python that's one
of the specific goals I mentioned which is
that you shouldn't have to speak Python to
use this new configuration format. It's in
the amo, I didn't actually mentioned what
amo is, yet another--amo is not markup language
I think is its name. Anyway, it's it is yet
another markup language similar to XML. And
hopefully the create wizard will just create
a wizard well enough free, you don't have
to actually have to do very much to it. One
of the things which we've looked at is actually
running this code using Jython on the Java
SDK so at least you don't have to download
Python, download the Python SDK. We've looked
at it, I don't have actually anything to report
interesting about that at that time.
>> Thank you for the presentations. So, I
have same kind of question on top of that.
So, is there any limitation for the file size
uploader?
>> BLAIN: Right, so that's why, so that is
the biggest pain point right now. So, we've
changed some of how the scheduling works in
App Engine, so that you can upload a little
bit better than that. Unfortunately, right
now, you do have to tune it and it is still
much slower than we'd like. So, you know,
we're looking a little bit of the performance
of it in the future but, sort of, my big hope
is actually that really soon we'd be actually
say instead of uploading the data piece by
piece which is why it takes so long because
it's this tons of overhead on every request
that we can just upload it through the server
all at once, this one giant blog and you say
the map functions to run over it and just,
and they'll run much quicker because instead
of this giant overhead for every single bit
of data, it's all quite close to each other.
>> So, your answer is currently...
>> BLAIN: Unfortunately, it's still pretty
slow right now and...
>> Just slower, you know.
>> BLAIN: It's slow and, yeah, exactly. I
mean, I've certainly seeing people with that
sort of greater, greater speed. And certainly
seeing stuff go much fast in that.
>> And there--is there any limitation about,
you know, App Engine is or, has a 30-second
rule per one request, right? So, is that the
case upright to the...
>> BLAIN: So, that's part of why the Bulkloader
runs on the client today is because App Engine
can't currently handle large amounts of data.
It can now, couldn't--it was originally created.
It can handle dealing of large amounts of
data, it can't handle request longer than
30 seconds. So right now, that's why the Bulkloader
runs on the client. They can talk to whatever
you client can handle amount of data and it
sends it bit by bit to the server using the
remote API which is why sort of the cool new
features we have dealing with, you know, not
produce, or long running processes will actually
alleviate that, but they're not there right
now so.
>> So, your planning you'll improve that kind
of [INDISTINCT]...
>> BLAIN: Yeah, specifically, something which
I'm actually really excited about those features
is because it let us solve this problem.
>> Continue the, you know, how quick their--you
were, release that kind of refraction, time
schedule.
>> BLAIN: Hopefully soon. I can't really say
anything about time but it is real, it's not,
you know, [INDISTINCT] but I don't have any
specific time on this.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> BLAIN: Yeah.
>> Hey, hi.
>> BLAIN: Hi.
>> I'm curious if you're planning to get some
graphical user interface. I don't know if
you're familiar with an application called
GEA BAR, that makes your back up and restore
a web interface. So, is that something planned
or stick to the compiler?
>> BLAIN: No plans for that at this time so.
Okay, yes. Okay, so, talk about this question.
So, the--I don't know the details of how ECG
based database has worked, but the fundamental
answer to this question is pretty much the
same actually get to any question about how
do I deal with data inside and outside of
App Engine, which is that everything's an
HTTP request. So the way Bulkloader works
that uses remote API to transfer information
from your local client to server, but, as
I said you can imagine the connector which
runs in your local workstation, connects to
Amazon, and talk to the server. And you can
also imagine something running on the server
using task queue or something which does an
HTTP request to your Amazon and sends, and
pulls the data back and forth. That's sort
of-–that's how the Bulkloader, so we can
run it with the client which talks to Amazon
or was in either direction. Yeah.
>> [INDISTINCT] Bulkloader does it support
a margin of the data like if I believe some
data in my local, [INDISTINCT] server too?
>> BLAIN: So, that's an important question.
When I mentioned keys are key, I didn't actually
go into detail what I really meant by that.
So, the Bulkloader, when it's running either
import or export is only doing either reads
or writes. So, when it's doing import of data
from your local workstation to App Engine.
All right, so it's importing to App Engine
that's the direction we're going here. It's
creating, it's doing a put for every single
entity that's in your input source to App
Engine. So, if you've not specified any keys
at all, App Engine will auto generate the
keys and it will be purely in append. If you
specify the key for every single row in your
data file, if they're all new it will all
be new entities, if you specify the key with-–which
is represents an existing entity it will be
an overwrite. So there's no specific delete,
that's one of the other features which people
very commonly ask for an App Enginem, "How
do I delete all my entities for this kind?"
And the answer right now is you can run on
a task queue, task over and the answer in
the future will be using some of the new technologies
that I've talked about. All right, similar
answer to the answer of the previous question,
I guess, I'm not exactly sure how the supplies
in the Bulkloader-–this is more used SDC
with HTTP so SDC is the Secured Data Connector;
it lets you, if you're applications inside
your firewall, it's a tool which lets you
communicate over HTTP through your firewall.
Our entity is written in order such that reference
properties are always valid. So this is, again,
my keys are key, if you're reference properties–-if
you have a way of calculating your keys for
every entity. So, again, if you're the user
and the email address you need for the user;
Wikipedia articles and you've got a specific
title for every article. Anytime you have
a reference to this, or even if you actually
use the gwid which your database has generated,
any time you have reference to this anywhere
you can use it. So, it doesn't matter what
order of things are written in, because you
can have a key which points to-–you can
have a reference property if it which points
the key in another entity even though that
entity doesn't exist. Now if you try to do
reference it, you got a failure because it
try to get the entity, it doesn't exist. But,
as long as you you've had created both entities,
you've created both the parent and the child
and the reference, by the time you actually
come around to reading the information is
there. So, about ordering-–the ordering
is not strictly guaranteed on upload because
it does stuff in parallel. On download, the
ordering is strictly guaranteed. Another feature
I didn't mention is that you can actually
specify by default when we run through it,
I said downloads everything just runs through
all of your data. Right now it runs through
in key order. There's a property can specify
on the amo where you can actually specify
an arbitrary sort of property. So, if you
have a bunch of other generating keys, you
can actually want to sort by email address.
You can actually specify the email address
should be the sort key on the upload. Invalid
characters; someone in this room probably
asked this.
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> BLAIN: So, okay. Yeah, so, the encoding,
and again, this is dry runs particularly useful
for this. The connectors in both the CSV and
XML connector support multiple encoding. So,
if you use the default [INDISTINCT] encoding
data is actually Windows 1252. You're likely
to get in there a part way through your file.
So, this is where dry runs particularly useful
because it will run through all of your input
data, and when you hit the end, no errors,
you're good to go. If it dies part way through
you, you've known before you even try to write
to your datastore that you've an error part
way through your file. All right, anybody
have questions? That's the end of the day,
and I guess you're all are welcome to hang
out. Talk me, I'll be here afterwards. I'll
probably be around, I'm, I'll be here in office
hours tomorrow. And if go to bulkloadersample@appspot.com,
you'll see all the samples, I guess. I'm just
matthew.blane@google.com if you have any questions
for me over email. All right. Thanks.